الخوف بالنسبة لي لا يعني شيئًا على الإطلاق
بعد الآن ، يلعب الخوف مثل هذه القطعة الكبيرة من
حياتي وسيطرني على عدم القيام
بما هو أفضل بالنسبة لي ، لذا فإن الخوف بالنسبة لي الآن
ليس سوى خيال
[موسيقى]
اسمي هو قلب رودريغيز أنا
هوليوود ستانت مان و American Ninja
Warrior من سن 9 إلى 15 عامًا
تعرضت للإيذاء الجنسي من قبل والدي ، مثل كيف
أعيش حياتي بعد ذلك كما لو أنني لا أستطيع
الوثوق بأي شخص دخلت في
رياضة الباركور والركض الحر عندما كنت في سن 19
Parkman freerunning هما
تعريفان مختلفان ، الباركور متشابه للغاية ، هو
مجرد القفز
فوق الجدران فوق أي عقبة في طريقك ،
إعادة الجري هو أسلوبك الخاص بك
، مما يجعله جميلًا وجميلًا
قدر الإمكان ، وتستغرق
وقتك عندما حصلت عليه لأول مرة  بدأت ، لم أكن مقلوبًا أبدًا ،
لذا فإن جسدي مثل الانتظار ،
لم نفعل ذلك ، ثم يأتي جانب الخوف ،
لذا يبدو الأمر كما لو أننا
نتوقف ونفكر في هذا الأمر ، هل هذا
يستحق حقًا أن نتأذى
[موسيقى]
الخوف هو ما أوقفني  جيئة وذهابا  لقد كانت محاولة
إيقاف الباركور
والركض الحر للاعتداء الجنسي بمثابة نقطة انطلاق
بالنسبة لي للشفاء وأكون على ما يرام مع اعتداءي
الجنسي ، لأن الخوف جزء كبير
من الباركور والركض الحر ، لذلك كل
يوم كنت أتدرب ، كنت دائمًا
أواجه خوفًا جديدًا.
بدأت في الموسم
الثالث من American and warrior ، ثم في الموسم السابع ،
شرحت قصتي أنني تعرضت للإيذاء الجنسي
بعد أن خرجت مقابلتي ، كان لدي
أطفال يكتبون لي أحد الوالدين الذي
اتصل بي تبين أن
الابنة والابن كانا كذلك  تعرضت للاعتداء الجنسي من
قبل صديق للعائلة ، من المؤكد أن الطفل
بدأ في الانهيار وهو يبكي ، كانت
كما لو أن ما يتحدث عنه الوجه قد
حدث لي أيضًا وقاموا بتوجيه
التهم التي أدين الرجل المحترم بها ، وقد
أذهلني ذلك
تمامًا لأنه لم يفعل ذلك فقط  أنا أعالج نفسي
لكنني أيضًا أنقذت شخصًا ما من المزيد من
الإساءات وكان ذلك أمرًا لا يصدق وأحب رد
الجميل للمجتمع باستخدام
قصتي.
حول
رياضة الباركور المجانية ، أحاول أن أعلمهم أدوات
الحياة ، أنتم يا رفاق رأوني سقطت
قليلاً ، ما الذي يجب أن تقوله يمكن
لكل شخص أن يتعامل مع الخوف ،
نعم ، لذا إذا كان بإمكاني تعليم هؤلاء الأطفال منذ
صغرهم أن يفصلوا الخوف  من الخطر
التي هي أداة
حياتية ، يمكنني الآن قلبها
وإلقاء الضوء عليها بمعنى هذا
هو ما أنا عليه هذا ما يحدث لي
، وانظر إلي ، فأنا ما زلت أشرق
لك